avec nous ce soir deux experts en
matière de politique de santé le
professeur adjoint olivier jacque de
l'université de montréal et damien
contandriopoulos du professeur à
l'université de victoria bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir alors qu on appelle ça
une contribution santé ou une taxe santé
oms vient taxes et celles et ceux qui
refusent la vaccination
olivier jacque d'abord est-ce que sur le
principe vous en pensez quoi est-ce que
c'était approprié
clairement le gouvernement veut montrer
à la population vaccinée qui fait pour
ses activités sans ce moment que lui
même et c'est de faire tout en son
possible pour augmenter le taux de
vaccination et nous sortir de la crise
ça pourrait avoir une conséquence
positive c'est à dire que ça pourrait
augmenter le taux de vaccination mais à
mon avis a deux conséquences néfastes
évidente c'est à dire que ça risque de
toucher disproportionnellement les
populations plus vulnérables et ça
risque de polariser encore plus le débat
sur la vaccination
damien contandriopoulos est ce que c'est
une mesure qui serait incitatives parce
qu'on parle d'un incitatif fiscal
certains diront que c'est punitif qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
en fait si on avait présenté comme étant
une contravention saisir une punition un
peu de la même façon qu'ils aient des
lois qui interdisent de tels excès de
vitesse si vous faites l'excellent site
s vous êtes punis
j'aurai moins de problèmes avec cette
mesure les endroits dans lesquels où les
situations dans l'obligation vaccinale
c'est généralement cette façon là que ça
marche on n'a pas
d'individus qui viennent vous chercher
qui vous sortir votre maison que vous
plantez de force une aiguille dans le
bras ça marche par des pénalités ou
l'emprisonnent ce qui me gêne beaucoup
dans la façon de la mesure a été
annoncée c'est l'idée d'une taxe santé
dans l'idée que les gens qui demandent
plus de soins doivent payer plus cette
idée là elle est en contravention direct
avec les principes sur lesquels on a
fondé le système de santé et c'est une
approche qui quand elle est essayée là
c'est cette notion à chaque soir arienne
plus vous êtes risque que vous payez
elle est inéquitable et inefficace et
elle est dangereuse si on la considère
comme un précédent pour le gouvernement
du québec est ce que ça serait
comparable
vieja qu'à une taxe sur le tabac ou le
sucre justement pour faire changer un
comportement ont dit on vous taxe vous
n'êtes pas vacciné on veut que vous
vacciner alors on impose une forme de
taxe pour faire changer un comportement
comme on peut le faire par exemple sur
le tabac ou le sucre oui on peut faire
cette comparaison la cédéthèque ce qu'on
appelle des taxes pigou viennent
mais par contre c'est certainement plus
pâle à 10 ans aucune taxe sur le tabac
puis arrêter de fumer le serait aussi
difficile que de se faire vacciner pour
les gens qui sont pas encore vaccinés je
pense il ya une différence assez
fondamental avec la taxe sur le tabac
c'est que c'est une surtaxe liée à
l'état de santé d'une certaine manière
donc on va taxer les gens pour un état
de santé c'est à dire la non vaccination
et comme damien l'a mentionné ça crée un
précédent qui est important on aurait pu
mois je brûlais financier on aurait pu
peut-être penser comme alternative de
continuer à élargir le porte-parole
vaccinale plutôt que d'aller vers cette
mesure à quel moment une taxe pourrait
être efficace un incitatif fiscal
pourrait être efficace pour amener les
gens damien contandriopoulos les
réfractaires à se faire vacciner
il faut voir jusqu'à quel point la
situation actuelle on est le problème
c'est réellement les gens qui sont
réfractaires à la vaccination
on a un taux d'oxydation pour la colline
près 90% québec c'est un taux
extrêmement élevé et un taux qui plus
est pour la plupart des vaccins comment
est ce qu'on voit avec la situation avec
au micro en particulier c'est que même
un taux de vaccination de 100% nous
sortirait pas de la pandémie donc il
faut voir combien comme société on est
prêt à investir en termes d'efforts avec
combien on est prêt à avoir de compromis
en termes d'éthique pour aller chercher
ce 10% dictionnaire puis 10 % c'est
normal hier des quand il faut rock latin
il ya des gens qui ont des problèmes de
santé mentale important et déjà qu'ils
sont qu'à la rue il ya des gens qui pour
toutes sortes de raisons même si on
impose une taxe ou un impôt
vont pas changer leur comportement juste
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas on va vous
le voyez comme un enjeux éthiques damien
contandriopoulos
tout à fait à partir du moment où on est
en train d'essayer de forcer les gens à
faire quelque chose qu'ils veulent pas
faire on peut pas faire abstraction de
la composante éthique intervention du
gouvernement en même temps on avait un
expert hier qui est économistes et
fiscalistes
daniel paillé qui disait ça prendrait un
impôt vaccinale pour les personnes qui
sont hospitalisées en raison de l'accord
et 19 et qui refusent de se faire
vacciner il le nomme comme un incitatif
fiscal est-ce que liégeois qu'à un
certain moment
ce n'est pas dans le coffre à outils une
possibilité que d'adopter une mesure
fiscale pour faire changer justement un
comportement oui c'est l'insigne
possibilité qui est envisageable ça peut
fonctionner par contre il faut vraiment
penser aux conséquences et moi je
penserai peut-être que ça pouvait être
pertinent de réfléchir à une taxation un
peu plus progressive pourquoi est ce que
on impose à tout le monde le même la
même taxe si on n'est pas vacciné on
pourrait par exemple imposer une taxe
qui ne serait uniquement que symbolique
à des gens qui ont mis très faible
revenu et une taxe plus élevée à des
gens qui ont des pulls des revenus plus
élevés on le fait avec l'impôt sur le
revenu et on pourrait le faire de cette
manière là et d'ailleurs heureusement
que le gouvernement n'est pas allé dans
le sens de ce que me suis payé proposée
lorsque celui ci proposait de payer
l'ensemble par exemple du coût de
l'hospitalisation
s'arrêter savaient qu'ils trouvent
certainement cela dit on a eu une
contribution santé de 2010 à 2017 qui
s'appliquait à l'ensemble de la
population
et si je me trompe pas monsieur compte
andriot pour l'os on applique aussi une
forme de contribution santé depuis
plusieurs années en ontario qui
respectent la loi canadienne sur la
santé
dans la mesure où tout le monde doit
payer oui c'est de la minceur la santé
au québec au canada et payés par le
biais des impôts généraux à quand cette
contribution additionnelle comme ça
c'est une contribution qui détachait du
revenu donc c'est moins équitable mais
plusieurs provinces ont fait plus à
prôner soient abandonnées ou si le
québec le faisait arrêter de la fin
quand le britannique le faisait arrêter
de le faire probablement parce que le
bénéfice réel est très faible je
reviendrai encore sur le fait que si on
commence à dire aux gens vous allez
payer un montant qui correspond aux
soins dont vous allez avoir besoin parce
que x factor de risque la commune en
étant on peut penser à plein d'autres on
est sur une pente glissante dans
laquelle on a plusieurs exemples de
système de santé qui ont fait ça en
pensant que c'est une bonne idée et qui
se retrouvaient en fait à avoir des
dépenses sont plus élevés et un des
drames au niveau humain et éthiques nous
sommes au début de cette discussion qui
a été lancée d'un coup sec que cet après
midi par le premier ministre le go nous
en reparlerons olivier jacque damien
contandriopoulos merci beaucoup merci
merci à vous pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit